Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
What is it? August 28th, 2017 what's going on how are you ?
Ahhh,
what's up? Sorry. It was obnoxious. I understand. I understand,
but I gotta make the lady shut it off first, right? Oh my God.
Who is this guy yelling?
Why would you want to listen to that when you could just,
you could just sit and watch reality television with myself.
Let's do a bunch of broads fucking yelling at each other. It's unreal.
It's unreal. My wife Watches that shit all the time. All the fucking time.
You come home and it's just like, it's like they live with us.
You know what I mean? Me and my wife, we give, hey, we get along great.
You know,
but you wouldn't know it walking up the fucking front walk to the house.
You hear like five women screaming at each other.
No.
It's just like, what are we hosting the Jerry Springer show? What's going on?
And you open the door and she's watching the real housewives of who gives a fuck
the real housewives of Trenton, the real housewives of Dayton, Ohio.
Wherever the hell they are,
okay?
Wherever they are, whatever city they're in, the real housewives,
they got fake tits. They got big ass fucking,
they got ass injection lips. They got the fucking Botox,
okay?
It's unbuttoned about where they are real housewives. Grand rapids you'd like,
there's not going to be some Hollywood shit guy and there it is.
Why is everybody walking around acting like there's some aging actress?
You know what I mean? And they somehow they have to look good for what the,
what the fuck are you looking at you if you ever 50 year old mom,
just be your mom. Relax. It's over. He landed a guy, he knocked you up.
All the laws are in your favor. For God's sakes.
Go have a fucking piece of pie and go smoke a camel.
I don't understand what the fuck these fucking spaghetti strapped women,
you know the stupid, they're still wearing the tag tops. You know what I mean?
Okay.
Jesus Christ with the fucking tired skin show.
And what are you doing trying to compete with your daughter? What are you doing?
Good Lola. Little take. Take a page out of my book. Just fucking,
just give into it here. Start falling out. Fucking shaving
your legs are two white. Put some pants on
your fucking guts. Getting too big. Start wearing sport coats on stage.
These are the [inaudible]. That's the classy way.
That's the classy way to just gracefully, you know,
go from being young into your middle aged and to just be an old.
This what you do. Then you get an old man hat, right?
You start pottering around, you make funny little jokes. Everybody. Lao,
we look at a look at that guy still making jokes. That's what you do.
Okay.
You don't get chemicals shot into your fucking face,
you know and enhance your fucking tits. Like what? What are you trying to do?
Huh? You're trying to give some 60 year old a hard on.
I don't understand what these women are doing. It was funny,
I didn't even want to talk about this shit. I just,
I don't know why that just came out. It just did. All right.
I had a wonderful show last night, a wonderful show. I was at the kid cod,
melody, melody tent, if I can say it,
which is a such a special place for me to do stand up because the one and only
time I ever saw the great George Carlin live was that the cape cod melody tent.
And I am embarrassed to say I saw him in 1988 and me and this other guy went to
go see him to laugh at him because my buddy had me convinced that he had stopped
writing and that he was still doing 20 year old bits.
So we were going to go see him as a joke.
If you can listen to how fucking stupid,
I was one of the most prolific comedians of all fucking time.
So we show up to laugh at this guy and within two seconds we were just on the
fucking floor laughing and the guy hit his brand new 90 fucking minutes and we
were driving home like he, he wasn't doing more stuff.
He wasn't doing fucking like, that's how dumb I was. Um,
I did a lot of dumb shit back then.
I went to some comedy shows and I was literally the person in the crowd.
I wasn't heckling or anything, you know what I mean?
Although one time I did heckle Don Rickles just cause I wanted to have an
interaction with them and I knew that I wasn't gonna meet him. You know,
I saw him at a casino about four years ago
and um,
I waited till his encore and he came out in the encore and he was just doing his
jokes, doing his jokes, and I was way in the back. He's playing this giant room.
I was way in the back and I just went, hey, it didn't say anything.
Kept doing his jokes, kept doing his jokes.
I waited like another three minutes and I went, Don, hey.
And he just looked out to where I was sitting. He goes, yeah,
I know my name made that fucking Rickles face. And I was with Bart,
nick and he fucking elbow. He goes, he hurt you. He hurts. And that was it.
You know,
I broke a major rule of engagement there with the fucking as a standup comedian.
I shouldn't have done it, but I couldn't help myself.
I could have helped myself. You know what? Let's be honest.
Why don't we just be honest? Okay. Now that,
that stupid fucking fight is over,
can we all just be honest with ourselves here?
I'm a selfish person in rather than accepting the fact that I wasn't going to
get an interaction with them, I had to do that because I'm a selfish cunt. Okay.
And, uh, you know, now can we all be honest about what went on Saturday night?
I gotta be honest with you. I have not even seen highlights of it.
I didn't fucking watch it. I actually came home and, uh,
I was staying with some relatives here in Boston who also didn't get the fight
cause they're sane people. They're like, yeah, it's just, you know,
he's Floyd's gonna carry him for a couple of rounds that he's going to finish
them and then they both, you know, they're not going to really each other up.
They're both going to leave with a boatload of money.
Isn't that what's going on here? Yeah.
Isn't there some Guy Alvarez who's actually a fucking modern day champion or
some shit like that coming up anyway, we'll spend the money on that.
We'll spend the money on that fucking thing, whatever that box and match.
I don't know shit about boxing, but I,
I do know Lal Zeto versus Muhammad Ali when I fucking see it.
So I mean a better version of it I should say. But anyways, um,
we actually watched a wicked tuna.
Yes.
I have such mixed emotions when I watched those fishing shows, you know,
I got this love of animals, but I also love tuna. You know,
I am of an environmentalist who loves crab, you know,
King Crab. Who the fuck doesn't love that? I mean,
that's just fucking tremendous.
So when they sit in and talking about how it's all fished out and they can't
find any and that type of stuff, you know,
it's not that we should stop crabbing.
They should just be less fucking people that they have to find it for, you know,
so, um,
you know,
I dunno, I always have all these fucking ideas of how to,
trimmed down the population. And of course I'm never part of the problem. Right.
As those, as most mass murdering maniacs,
you're never part of the problem like Hitler.
I'm sure when he looked in the window, the window looked in the mirror,
right and was brushing his fucking teeth. Right.
I'm sure that he saw a blonde haired blue eyed person.
Okay.
Instead of seeing what he truly was, which was the runt of the litter,
you know what I mean? But the guy had heart,
any fucking overcame what the fuck he looked like to achieve his dream.
You know, granted he was out of his fucking mind, but I mean,
that alone should've just see, should've been, if he wasn't so crazy,
it would have been, well, look at me.
I'm fucking ugly as Shit and look what I've achieved.
You know
what? If somebody who looks like me actually had a good heart,
imagine what they would achieve. Isn't that why?
We'll have fucking loan to ticket. Why,
why we y'all fucking loan a ticket is that guy, they're like, you know,
my dream came true and I played the Cape Cod melody tent telling jokes.
His dream came true and fucking, you know, tens of millions of people died.
That was literally his dream.
You know,
like imagine if he never did his shit right and he just lived a regular life and
then all of a sudden God, fuck why came? Say God forbid it's him.
I just naturally say, God forbid when I talk about terminal disease,
Adolf Hitler, right? Doesn't fucking, you know,
somebody bought his paintings or some shit, right?
So he just doesn't go down that fucking road. Now he's just, you know,
some regular guy and a, and then he has like, he,
he gets some terminal illness and for some reason make a wish, wishes back then.
And they'd go, what? What is your dream? What is your wish? And then he,
and then he g rarely you're gonna make my wish come true. This is what we do.
Eight off. We make sure your day with a smile on your face.
What is your dream? And he would have laid there, you know,
telling the guy to come a little bit closer. What do you want to do?
I want to exterminate all of the Jews. That's what he would've said.
And what a fucking quagmire that make a wish would have been.
They would have had to have, they would have to, hey, hang on a second,
they'd have to step out in the hall going, I, what do we do here? I mean, I,
you know, I mean we, we, we,
we just kind of made a broad statement that we make dreams come true. We,
we didn't clarify it. Like, what,
what do you want to stand out here long enough?
Maybe he'll fucking die the disease. I mean, our whole reputation's on the line,
right? And then all of a sudden make a wish gets dragged into it,
gets dragged into the madness of this man and then no longer looked upon as this
wonderful organization that they are. Right.
Which takes in millions and millions of dollars. Right?
And God knows what the fuck they do. Who knows?
You never know what those charities,
right.
Are they helping people out or are they helping themselves to a classic Camaro
with some tea tops. When we return, we'll be taking some callers. Sorry,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about today. Um, so anyways, yeah,
everybody thought I was going to cave. I have not caved on two fronts.
I have not drank in 11 days. And I feel this is that dude. I go 11 days.
I could go a year, I could go a fucking year.
I feel fucking fantastic. And I just used the word fantastic.
I never thought fantastic. You know,
I'm doing cardio like I've always been doing,
but I'm not negating it at night with the fucking three or four home pours over
there with the giant ice cube. Um,
and it's actually, the sober life is fucking great. It just sucks at night.
That's the only thing at night. It sucks at night, you know,
because it's like, what the fuck do I do? Um, I'm like, yeah,
like I'm a habit guy, so this is the time of night.
I fucking do this and then I'm not doing it. I'm like, well now what do I,
what do I do? So, you know, I did, I started playing guitar again. Anything,
you know, I suck. What do you want? I mean it just, I go in there,
I fucking play a little bit and during that time and then it gets late and then
I literally feel my body just go on and come on and do it. Go pull one,
go that's right over there and look at the bottle, do look the bottle,
my dead boy yourself one. And I just,
all I have to do is just go downstairs to my bedroom.
And then the fact that I'm an old man takes over. Like God, Dude,
I am not fucking going all the way back up there. He's an animal.
He's not even as I'm laying there,
you know?
Yeah. I go downstairs and my angel liver,
a wife is laying in bed watching five women. She doesn't know,
screaming at each other and say horrible things. You know,
they're really big on attacking. Like, if a woman's never had a child,
they're really big on attacking that file, man, that fucking mean,
just Goddamn fucking main people, you know,
it's dumb as guys are the way we solve shit with violence. I just think,
you know,
just punching somebody in the face is way more civil than say,
well that's why you're barren and you can't have a child. It's like,
really? Do me a favor next time, just punch me in the nose when that just being,
can we just, can we just leave it at that?
So there's something to salvage afterwards. Jesus Christ. Um,
so many, but now that I've gone 11 days, now it's just starts to fade.
Like I don't even, I walk by my, my fucking, I told you 19,
27 Yankees lineup worth of fucking booze and I'm telling you, like,
I don't even see it anymore. Like, you know, I don't, I don't, I don't,
I get murderer's row murderer's row, the shit that I drink.
Um, you know, and then they're all, I have the batting order,
you know what I mean? Top of the order,
right through cleanup is the top of the shelf top shelf shit.
You know that shit. Pappies I say you.
Okay. Here we go. Let's go with booze. So what would you line up? B?
Who's hitting lead off? Who's getting on base? Right?
Who's your fucking Ricky Henderson?
That's gonna fucking possibly hit a solo shot and the next guys don't even have
to knock them in. You know what I'm going to say? I'm going to go
my Ricky Anderson is Johnny Walker blue.
Okay.
Oh, this is going to be hard. I've got too many cleanup hitters. Dan.
I would say baton second is grand patrol.
All right. I'm not a big Tequila guy,
so I'm not getting into that fucking a Gavi shit. Where the fuck they put in it?
Yeah. Then I would say, ah, this is a hard one.
I would say maybe some pappy van winkles is going third.
Then Bat and cleanup in my world,
I would say is a McCallum rare cask.
Right
now we're getting to the middle of the order. This is a, you know,
it's not a special occasion. I just want to get fucked up.
All right.
These are the guys hitting two 70 to 80 then you get in the middle already.
You got Johnny Walker Black, his bat and fifth
I'd say no. Fifth is patroned silver. Johnny Walker Black
is baton sixth and seventh, eighth and ninth.
Now you're talking companies coming over. You like these people, but they don't,
they don't like appreciate good boots.
So you're just going to hit them with some basic shit, right?
That's when you have to go maker's mark,
Jack Daniels batting ninth
batting ninth. If someone wants to mix it, I'll give you, this is the fuck this.
This is the national league. When the pitcher bads. Johnny Walker.
Red Label.
There you go. That's my line guy. You know what? Semi me your booze lineups.
Okay.
Probably should've had. I can do the beer one
lead off Scott to be Budweiser. You know that? Thanks. Getting on fucking base
right
that second. I would have a Miller high life.
That and the third. No, no. Let me see. I'm going to give a fuck.
I got the, I don't know, lead off cores light.
No, but we were doing best beer all the way down, not on, oh,
what am I doing here? What am I doing here? All right. I am, I am.
I am white trash when it comes to beer. Okay.
The fanciest, I mean, I'll go, I would say, all right,
I go Budweiser, then Miller.
Hi Life. [inaudible].
Then I'd say, uh, Ben,
third Benton third and beer.
That's a tough one.
Okay.
You start wondering, people clear the basis a little bit.
I'll go a little snobby and I will say Blue Moon.
I don't mind the orange slice. I don't mind it. Like I, if I want,
if I'm just fucking thirsty, I'll have one of those bat and cleanup is Guinness.
All right.
Then I'd have a black and Tan fifth
six. Now you're just getting, now you want to get fucked up, right?
But you don't want to get your fucking going to become a fat fuck.
So I would say core is light, light beer.
Famila now eight and nine.
Okay.
Eight and nine. This is for when some, you know,
some older people are coming over with their kids and you just get a fun,
I dunno, for whatever fucking reason you gotta have an IPA.
And when I was at this like a Sierra Nevada or some shit, I would,
something like that. I don't drink, but I mean I'd leave that alone.
This isn't this a stupid, as Congress,
I'm literally fucking sober and I'm making bows, batting lineups. All right.
If you're a beer drinker or if you're a hard liquor, you know,
I want to hear your lineups. Okay, let's get ready man.
Up The fucking pennant races are heating up. All right.
I want to, I want to see what you line up. Sorry.
You come walking up to the bar with your little pulling your met your fucking
lineup card out of your back pocket. Um,
by the way, that Blue Moon eyes is signed to like a one year contract. You know,
you don't, you just pick up a fucking big bat at the end of the fucking season.
Like he, you know, he's not, he's not a true red sock. Um,
all right. So anyways, by the way, somebody tweeted at me,
that's stupid company out there and fucking Wisconsin.
It microchipping their fucking employees and these fucking idiots are doing it
and you know, and I'm like, why would they do that?
And then all you have to do is look at their faces and you look at them,
they, I have this childlike innocence. They are believers.
That's all it is.
They grew up in a great state of Wisconsin where you're sheltered. All right?
You're in the Midwest. You are in the hat of the country.
That fat fucking weasel in North Korea is missiles.
Even if it makes it that far, he's not shooting it at Wisconsin. Right?
The Green Bay packers did they like owned by the fans?
It's fucking everybody's making cheese. It's Mayberry.
You ever been to Wisconsin? It's fucking tremendous.
The air is fresh. The water is fucking clean. At least it looks that way.
When I drive by at 80 miles an hour and awaiting some God for Sake and fucking
place, I'm going to perform at
right.
It's tremendous. Fuck these people, they believe,
right?
They all ordered the fight.
Okay.
They think he's gonna make it great again. They just, they believe,
you know why? Cause they're fucking good people out there.
So they walk into the workday, hey guys, this is the new thing. And they,
and they sit there looking, Gio, no, this seems a little bit creepy, right?
But how did they get them and how do you get,
how do you get the general masses? How do you get them all right?
There's two ways to get the general masses fear and free tee shirts.
One or the other.
You scare the shit out of them. They're fucking on board.
You tell him the boogie man's under their bed,
whatever the fuck you tell them they need to do, they got to fucking do it.
If you don't want to fucking waste your time coming up some fucking bogeyman
story, just make a free fucking tee shirt.
And that's what they did in Wisconsin.
They had these fucking tee shirts that said, I got shipped.
That was it. That was, that was the tipping point. Wait a minute.
If I put that foreign object in me that I have no idea what it is,
no idea what its capabilities are.
No idea what it really does other than what you tell me you evil cunt,
you'll give me that free tee shirt and you know they got on the extra soft ones.
Oh my God, Dude. My, I tell you right now, my favorite,
my favorite Goto tee shirt is my, I got chipped.
It's so soft, you know?
Then as much as I'm making fun of them,
I see the writing on the wall because there's way more people.
There's way more believers out there, you know,
believing in the invisible lines, believing in the teams,
believing in all that fucking bullshit, right? Believe in it,
they're evil, but these people are saints or vice versa, right?
These people are, they do it. They do it all over the world.
Okay?
God loves us best. These people are infidels. These people are fucking Dez.
These people are fucking that.
It's the thing is that common thread with human beings is that this fucking
lunatics at the top. Okay.
And then you have nice people at the bottom, you know, Wisconsin people,
people give the shirt off you fucking back, you know,
provided you not to 10 let's, let's not,
let's not overly romanticize these white people. At the end of the day,
they are white people. Okay? And I'm not shitting on my own.
People were just in a position. It's a society my way. You know,
nobody's watching us so we get to go full fucking, you know,
full fucking frontal nudity with their fucking brains. There's nobody,
there's nobody in our way, right? That's why we guys where we go fucking crazy.
You need some sort of hand on, maybe that's what the microchip is for.
I have no idea. I just know at the end of the fucking trail, who is it?
Because some of the people that run shit, look at Bill Clinton.
The man could not keep his dick in his pants. He shoving cigars up,
women's vaginas half his fucking age. That fucking guy that,
that's one of the guys run shit or someone of his fucking ill Keegan.
Let that guy put a fucking microchip. What do I get? A free tee shirt? Yes,
you don't skippy I write, I'm in. And that's it.
And this is the thing they don't need.
They don't need thinking people to buy in.
All they need is the free tee shirt people in the free tee shirt people.
You get enough of them,
it becomes a tipping point and then they can start changing.
You know what I mean? It's like the toll booths, right? Everybody easy pass.
I'm not getting now. You're not gonna fucking track where I'm going. Right.
And it was just one easy pass lane.
10 fucking lanes where you threw your change in or fucking went to a guy, right?
And then it became eight, seven, six, five, four, three, two, one.
Go Fuck Yourself. Well, you don't have to,
you can use the fucking surface roads. You don't have to use the highways,
but your taxes did pay for them. Then you're like, fuck, that's what happens.
And they'll get all of us. Do you know what?
Okay.
You know what I love about life though?
They can never stop you from drinking yourself to death.
Okay?
And that's one to grow on. All right. With that, let's, uh,
sorry that got really fucking dark. Um,
all right. What are we doing here? Uh, live reads. Okay.
I'm reading off my phone here because I have no internet where I'm at right now.
I'm gonna have to go drive down to a fucking coffee shop.
Yeah.
You know,
there's nothing in a coffee shop that I want other than their internet.
You know, I don't drink coffee. Your, your little pastries.
Are they like eating a fucking bathroom tile? They're always fucking up.
They just suck. Everything in Starbucks fucking sucks.
I don't, I don't have the coffee. I know the coffees that heroin. All right,
but do you ever go into a bodega that's really selling fucking drugs?
You know what I mean? You know, like oldest serial is, that's what that's like.
What fucking like a Starbucks is.
It's like a drug deal in Bodega.
Yeah.
Do you know what I mean? And like the only thing that, that,
that is good in there that is, that is not past,
it's fucking date of freshness is the fucking drugs that this cell in.
And what Starbucks. It's the coffee. Everything else in this sucks.
That's why you've gotta Love Dunkin Donuts, you know?
Okay.
The copy evidently is out of this fucking world, but they also make,
they make these great doughnuts. All right. Draftkings everybody
a fantasy for all shit. Draftkings is back.
I love these guys because they finally admitted what the fuck they were doing.
All right. All right. She fucking degenerate. Gamblers. Hey, you go.
You're in a loveless marriage.
Let's add to the pain draft kings fantasy football season is almost here and
there's no better way to get closer to the game you love than to put your
fucking paycheck on it.
With draft kings one week fantasy football draft kings is hosting a $100,000
contest. That is totally free to enter.
All you have to do is put your paycheck down and if, yeah,
and if you don't draft the perfect lineup, you can what?
And if you drafted the perfect lineup,
you can win $1 billion.
Okay?
All right. I was making fun of this. Now I think I'm in with draft kings.
There are many ways to play.
Choose between public contest with big cash prizes or private contest where you
can compete against a group of your friends.
Draftkings also has a beginner and casual contest where you play against people
of a similar skill level.
That's like when the drug dealer gives you a free taste.
The best part is do you get to draft a new team each week without any
commitment. So to get draftkings.com now and use a,
so get draftkings.com now and use Promo Code Bar B U R R to play a draft king
free week one contest with $100,000 in total prizes.
And if these guys are brilliant and if you don't,
if you draft the perfect lineup, you can win $1 billion.
I don't know what the perfect lineup is.
Use My promo code bird to play for free and week one. That's Promo Code
bur@draftkings.com eligibility restrictions apply.
See draft kings.com for details. I love that they're back in the ring.
I want to see, I want to see that movie get made. Oh,
how they came about, how quickly they grew,
and now quickly at the state and federal level, they're like, wait a minute,
this is a national drought gambling ring and we're not getting any fucking money
out of this.
How many beaks did you have to fucking wet to get back into the game?
Geez, I bet they went to one of those Bilderberg makes all right.
He like started. He looks at me when Alex,
I don't what the fuck this is I your your unique. Oh, you're a special person,
aren't you? You don't walk like everyone else talk like everyone else.
Cho Chat or anything or anyone else or sleep like anyone else.
So why the fuck is your mattress? One size fits?
I don't know, because there's a basic shape to everybody. Um,
because a truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 bucks. Oh,
there's the answer right there. Until now, go to helix,
sleep.com and answer a few simple questions and they'll run a three d
biomechanical model of your body through their proprietary algorithms they
developed with the help of the world's leading iRig Ranomics and biomechanics
experts, Jesus Christ. What a sentence. The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on.
Helix customers report a 30% improvement in overall sleep quality and for
couples, they customize each side of the mattress. I, yes,
the beginning of the end of the relationship,
your mattress arrives at your door in about a week and shipping is 100% free.
I like mine to be like this. Yeah, I like it to be like that.
I'd rather fuck this guy. I don't give a shit. I'm already banging her.
He looks asleep.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are all talking about helic
sleep. You have 100 nights to try it out and if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free, gross and give you a 100% refund.
No questions asked. Be Funny if they asked you what was the problem?
I mean sleeping was okay, but when I went to Bang my wife,
I kept getting this pain in my left knee. Yeah, you know I played sports, but I,
you know, I never had painted that one. Look,
my fucking knee hurts when I banged my wife. I don't want to tell you.
All right, I'll sign there. All right,
go to Helen's sleep.com/ [inaudible] and get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/burr hey. Hello sleep.com/bird h.
E. L. I. X. Oh Jesus.
Look who's back movement watches. Everyone hang in there. I got two more here.
Movement watches. You guys know movement, right?
They reinvented the watch business by selling directly to you with over 1
million watches sold to date. Well, you God damn it,
these bastards did it again except this time with sunglasses. Nah,
you thought they were done with watches. Now they're going to keep going.
They just shot one right across the bow of every designer.
Fucking sunglass boat out there. They were tired of having a pay.
They were tired of having to pay for cheaply.
Made throwaway shades or overpriced designer glasses. So they said, fuck it.
They actually wrote, screw it. They said, fuck it. You know,
that's what they said in the meeting.
We'll make our own starting at just 70 bucks.
Movement sunglasses start at just $70 with the option to upgrade to polarized,
um, with over. What the fuck does that mean? Polarized.
You stop agreeing with people the second length you fucking,
he's a polarizing character. Um, those overpriced designer brands will,
will run you upwards of 200 bucks.
Movement figured out by selling online.
They were able to cut out the middleman and retail markup providing the best
possible prices. They figured this out with watchers. They're like, hey,
why not do it? I'm glad I did. I hope they keep going.
We've done it again. We've cut out the middleman with fucking Dildos,
uh, where they are. High quality premium. I don't know how to say it's a c.
E t. A t. E s Tate acetate.
[inaudible]. He takes frames. No cheap plastic care. You got to see these.
They have a lot of styles to choose from. Classy, trendy,
round aviator married, polarized.
You know, if I had the internet, I'd look that up. Polarized sunglasses.
What the fuck does that mean? You wear them down in Antarctica,
a for him and for her. Uh, you're sure to find the perfect pair.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to [inaudible]
dot com slash burr. You know,
Movement for how they've revolutionized the watch industry.
Now's the time to check out their sunglasses. Go to M v M
t.com/burr join the movement. All right, last one. Oh God.
Why is this copy so long? Just get to the fucking point. Wink,
W I N C for some reason pronounced wink.
When you have a great glass of wine,
it enhances the moment whether you're reflecting on, I, you know,
if I had to make a wine lineup, this is what it would be. Who's leading enough?
You gotta get lead off with a cat. All right man. You fucking,
uh, bottom of the order.
I don't know who the fuck I w all I know is a Barolos baton cleanup for me and I
don't give a fuck about anything else. About why, you know what I mean?
I take on the whole wine world, but just the two of those nice fucking cab.
If I want to get shit face Barolo, if I don't know if I did something that day.
All right? Uh, when you have a great glass of wine, it enhances the moment.
Whether you're reflecting on the day or with someone you love.
Wink understands this. It's why they started their company.
I mean how many times we have to tell you this is why they fucking did it.
To give you access to exceptional wines from around the world.
So you can have more of these moments. See I need to use it.
But if I wasn't on the wagon, I'd use this shit cause I,
cause if you can't put together a nine fucking bottle list of booze,
bear our wine, I guess liquor I should say, then,
then you know you're really doing your liver a disservice.
Just try winc.com t r Y W I N c.com.
Take a brief palate profile quiz and w you know,
and somehow that'll end up on somebody's microchip in their fucking hand in
Wisconsin and Winkel recommend distinct and interesting wines actually
customized to your pallet to be shipped directly to your door every month.
None of your time is what?
You'd be funny if you committed a murder years later and you left the fucking
wineglass and they went back to this information.
Well it says here that that wineglass was part of your profile.
Is that not true? It's part of your palate profile.
Then you get all nervous. He just confessed to it on the stand, right?
Like it's the 1950s cop show.
They were tired of having to pay for cheaply made throwaway wait.
That's the shades. Like what did I do here?
None of the your time is wasted fitting in a run to the store or your way home
from work or your way to an event or a gathering.
No more time spent guessing what you might like because wink basis the wines
they send you on your taste preferences, wink,
we'll even introduce you to new rare custom wines that are not available
anywhere else and tell you the story behind each one. No membership fees.
Skip any month,
cancel anytime and wink has a a hundred percent satisfaction guaranteed so you
never pay for a bottle you don't like.
And right now Winc is offering listeners $20 off your first order.
When you go try, go to try winc.com/bird that's try Winc, spelled t,
r y w I n c.com/bar to get $20 off your first order.
Now try winc.com/barb there you go. Oh, thank God. It's fucking over.
Thank God it's fucking over. No, Jesus Christ.
You don't. One thing I do like about tech technology, I like docusign.
I really enjoy that shit. Makes it nice and fucking easy. Um, oh, by the way,
I have to, I have to hight this gig because they don't do a lot of,
they don't do a lot of standup at this venue. Now at this point,
if you listen to the podcast for a while now you realize that you know as much
as old freckles goes on stage telling jokes,
he's actually a frustrated musician. You know,
I wish I was good at guitar. I wish I was good at trumps.
I have a tremendous amount of respect for you musicians. Speaking of which,
Queens of the Stone Age,
one of my favorite bands of all time put out their brand new album this week.
I'm going to be listening to it and I'll give you my own review of it on
Thursday. Just kidding. I fucking hate when people do that,
that I'm supposed to listen to you. Who the fuck are you? You know,
fucking listen to you. I'll listen to it myself. Make up my own mind.
How about that? How about that? All right. They youtube person, youtube person.
Anyways, I'm going to be a November 2nd. I'm going to be in clear lake,
Iowa at the surface ballroom. Know the surf ballroom is the,
that's the last place buddy Holly, the big Bopper, Richie Valens,
all of those guys played.
Waylon Jennings was there that night and he went on the bus and everything. Um,
just being a music fan, I don't know if it's slightly morbid to play there,
but I'm going to play there and I'm flying in.
I'm landing at the fucking airport. They took off from everyone. They go,
Angie fucking nervous.
They crashed because there was no de icing technology back then.
They had too much weight on their wings,
which changed the shape of the air foil. They were overweight.
They could fucking produce enough lift. They crashed and they die.
That's not going to happen in 2017 so I'm going to be there. Won't happen to me.
It won't happen to you. If you want to check out this legendary venue, uh,
November 2nd clear lake, Iowa surf ballroom.
I'm going to be there with Dean del Ray, um,
who was actually born the same day that they all died.
Not the same year but the same day. So it's going to be,
that's going to be tremendously freaky fucking night.
I've got a brand new hour and last night I, it could not have gone better.
And I left out half of my fucking jokes. I was having so much fun.
I'm down at the Cape Cod Melody Tent,
so please get your tickets November 2nd clear lake, Iowa, the surf ballroom.
And I will be tweeting out and Facebooking out a link because I am an old man.
I'm not on Photoshop. I'm not on Instagram. It's not Photoshop.
What's the other one? That is Instagram. And then there's the other one.
Snapchat. I need to get on those, right?
Is that what I need to do a, by the way,
I'm thinking of putting together a college tour,
a tour of colleges in the beginning of next year, um,
to help promote F is for family and bringing a bunch of swag to,
uh, you know, free merchandise, free efforts for family merchandise.
This is what I want to do. If I get enough interest from certain schools,
especially the University of Kansas,
when the Jayhawks have a home basketball game,
so I can go to that legendary arena, that would be tremendous.
Do you understand what I'm saying here?
I was actually thinking of doing that once a year, right in every like,
you know, college fucking, um, division. You know,
like one year I'll do a big 10 fucking f is for family tour. I'll do an SCC one,
I'll do a pack 12, whatever the fuck they're called now. Um, the whack,
right. Do something like that. I don't know.
I'm always thinking a fucking ideas like that shit, but uh,
just to help promote it and um, yeah, cause that's my fucking job.
I've got to sell the goddamn shoving. Don't get mad at me. Right. All right,
37 minutes in. Here we go. Here we go. All right, let's uh,
let's read some of your questions here for this week. I'm up, up, up, up, up,
up, up the nineties. Dear Billy temple pilot,
I'm feeling a bit nostalgic for the 90s. I was 12 and 1990.
I'm 10 years older than you.
You have bested and had no stress or responsibilities.
I get how that influences this, but it was a good time.
I'm happy with technology now in our society is more conscious of social issues,
but everything is so loud now.
Do you ever get into stylistic for the nineties if so,
what part of the nineties can you have your podcast guy use the friends theme
song for the Thursday podcast? That's a question mark there or anything.
Awesome from the 90s uh, thanks for reading this. If you do,
life is pretty boring these days. And if I could use something,
uh, to brighten my day as a pet store manager. All right sir.
Here's what's happening to you as you're slipping into your life and you don't
like what's going on. So rather than fixing the, now you're going back in,
that's not, I mean that's, that's a temporary fix. Okay.
If you don't want to manage a pet store,
asked yourself what you really want to do and start slowly walking towards that,
taking a half a step,
a quarter step every day in one point you're going to look up and God damn it,
there it is.
Just like Indiana Jones and then you grab it and all of a sudden a giant ball
starts rolling after Ya and you gotta fucking run out of there and that's you
after you make it, then trying to stay there. All right.
But that's way more exciting than managing this pet store that, you know,
you're saying brighten your day as a pet store manager.
You one of these guys who actually doesn't like animals.
You probably don't like the people right coming in there or whatever.
I don't know what it is but it's, but I will answer your question.
My favorite part of the 90s
was the month before nevermind came out and I was listening to the skid row
slave to the grind and I thought hair metal and all night when the hair metal,
but metal was never going to end cause that was what you love was the end of my
youth because I was 22 in 1990 so that was the end of the end of it for me.
So like think about 2000 for you. You're getting out of college,
all this new music is coming out. You're starting to not be able to, you know,
the next few years, you can't keep up with it.
What the fuck are they listening to? And then that's what happens.
And then you start driving around.
But I'm not gonna let you do this shit that I, I still listened to 'em
you know, I try to listen to newer shit. Like, you know, it's a new band in me,
like Cold War kids and I'm like, I saw them, you know, recently they were on TV.
I'll download some of this stuff and I'll be like, oh, I remember that song,
that fucking ball. Bam, my bow [inaudible] son.
Wow.
Fucking soon. The guy's singing away the really high voice, amazing voice. And
I was looking at that. It's like that fucking album came out 2006 or something.
So I'm way behind the curve, but I try to stay up on, all right,
you want to hear some embarrassing, I'm going to fucking tell you all my latest,
my latest downloads.
I downloaded Dreamweaver by Gary Wright,
that album tremendously.
Tremendously fucking a underrated album.
All right. Cause everybody thinks of, uh,
they think of that song.
We, we'll, we'll train way BA
right. And everybody laughs at that song, you know,
they use it in these ironic history hipster fucking ways. I gotta tell you, man,
that fucking album is the shit.
And I'm just stuff is some poppy shit on that. But, um,
all these years of me talking about loving to play drums and all this stuff,
why did nobody tell me about Andy Newmark? Jesus Christ.
That guy's one of the best fucking drummers I've ever heard he plays on this
album. And uh, you know,
you don't have to get it for fucking dream weaver or any of that, but like, uh,
love is alive.
The longest time I thought that sounded like clapped into me singing or maybe
like one of those, uh, Steve Winwood bands.
Um,
just listen to how tasty the fucking drums are.
And I'll actually post a video this week of him fucking playing with like Rod
Stewart and these guys just fucking Whalen. All right. So I downloaded that.
Then I downloaded Cold War kids, Robertson cowards.
I'm downloading the new queens of the stone age today. And then here's,
oh Jesus, he's in defense to me.
I lost a lot of my music when I dropped my last phone into the toilet. Um,
it was actually in my back pocket and I stood up from taking,
taking a dump. Right? No, no I didn't. I didn't, I was fucking hammered.
I remember this guy was saying there was something about standing up when you
take a Piss, some fucking health reason. So I sat down like a lady, right?
And I had my phone in my back pocket when I stood up at fucking fell into the
toilet. Fucking brutal. Like I was going to go get that. Nah,
it ain't happened. And so I don't use the cloud and everything.
Just I lost everything. So I downloaded ac DC. If you want blood, you got it.
Live ACDC for those about to rock AC DC high voltage.
Then I had to get my vintage Arrow Smith in there. I downloaded get your wings,
rocks, toys in the attic.
Then I downloaded the new fucking mute math. While I'm on waiting,
I'm still waiting for the rest of that album. Come out to play dead.
I downloaded Glen Campbell rhinestone cowboy cause I've been singing that with
the advertising Lako Rad stone ball bag. Uh,
Peter Frampton, Frampton comes alive. All Jay's,
all j a this is all yours. Marvin Gaye, sexual healing download.
Let a fucking tremendous song that is the new royal blood album.
Um,
Anthony Hamilton. Then I downloaded like three prints,
albums not to have them sign of the times and then a dirty mine,
the first Soundgarden album, the prince album for you.
Then uh, Dave Brubeck live at Carnegie Hall,
then a bunch of miles Davis. That's what I've done in the last couple of months.
Steaming with miles, working with miles round about midnight,
relaxing with miles, cooking with miles. And there you go.
That's what the fuck had been downloaded. What else do I gotta get?
Wayne shorter. The idiot king. Attention deficit.
I think that's a, Oh, that's what's his face.
Tim Alexander on drums on that, the brown album.
Bad Motor finger. Temple of the dog. Oh,
that was right when I'm Chris Cornell died.
I had to get all that fucking music back on my phone. John Coltrane,
Sonny Rollins, Tesla skid they ago.
Marilyn Manson prime is prime as Primus animals should not act like people.
Pork, soda and sailing, the seeds of cheese.
You know Derosa just sent me a new fucking,
they knew their latest fucking track. It's the shit. I absolutely loved it.
Primus has a new one coming out with the fuck is it called? Let me see here.
Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? And my phone and my phone in my phone.
All right. What do I have him underneath? You know,
everybody says Joe has no shoulders. That's not true.
He lacks the meat that is between your neck and your shoulders basically is
trapped. He's, he's, he was born without it. Um, all right, Primus,
the seven. Check that out this week. All right.
Enough with this old man telling you the music that he likes.
Let's get back to your young people questions here, shall we? So, um, yeah,
when grunge came in, I got up. I didn't like the first,
like when Pearl jam first came out in Nevada, first came out,
I didn't like those bands because they knocked all my bands off the top 10.
You know, I was like, this isn't a good band. What about Brittany Fox?
What about winger, man? What about warrant? Um, yeah, I listened.
I didn't necessarily buy all those albums,
but I didn't think any of that was bad music. I was young.
I didn't fucking know any better, you know,
at least those guys could fucking play under these cons today with a fucking
laptop and a God damn Christmas tree in their head. Um,
so it took me a long time to admit that nirvana pearl jam were great bands,
but like Soundgarden and fucking Alison chains had like fucking that anger in
there. Um, and just the sound of the lead singers,
man, I just, I really liked their front men and uh, now of course, you know,
I love Pearl Jam. I love Nirvana and all that shit,
but I was a bit of a baby when their music came out. I was, I was too young.
This is the first time I've seen my music go away.
So I wasn't mature enough to be like, you know what, you know,
I have to accept that, uh, you know,
my time has come and gone and that this is what the fucking music is now and I
should listen to him. It took me a good 20 years to be able to do that.
All right. Hey there, Billy Clinton. Uh, did you, did you hear this yet?
The court ruled that the head of
the Democratic National Convention Debit Wasserman, that's her name, Dib. It
Sholtz rig the primaries against Bernie Sanders.
The court. What court.
So this woman under the influence of Hillary Clinton's camp tampered in the u s
election process, but none of the Democrats are celebrity.
Do rights are going to be outraged because there's sanctimonious ass hats.
And for the record, I was a registered Democrat and stop fucking saying that.
If it's a fact, it's a fact. I don't need to,
I used to be or this or I actually voted for Obama.
I don't give a fuck what you did. If what you're saying is factual,
I don't need to know what the fuck you did. I was a registered Democrat.
It's about 2010, but blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
With the exception of Bush and Gerald Ford A. Anyways,
the hypocrisy is just so insane to me to not be mad at this,
especially as a democrat. I think you have to have clinical issues. Yeah. Well,
I heard like Bernie Sanders was drawn a bunch of people and they just didn't
even cover it. All right. Now where does this coming from? This is the, uh,
the observer.com.
June, 2016,
a class action suit was filed against the Democratic National Committee and the
former Democratic national, uh, oh, it's Debbie,
Debbie Wasserman Schultz for violating, uh,
the DNC charter by rigging the Democratic presidential primaries for Hillary
Clinton against Bernie Sanders. How hilarious would this be?
It's actually doubly sad if this is true.
Even former Senate minority leader Harry Reid admitted in July,
2016 I knew everybody knew that this was not a fair deal.
He added that Debbie Wasserman Schultz should have resigned much sooner than she
did.
The lawsuit was filed to push the Democratic National Convention to admit their
wrongdoing and provide Bernie Sanders supporters who supported him financially
with millions of dollars in campaign contribution with restitution for being
cheated on August 25th,
2017 federal judge Williams Schlei is this all true,
dismissed the lawsuit after several months of litigation during which the
Democratic National Convention to attorneys that argued that the DNC would be
with, well within their rights to rig primaries and select their own candidates.
That was their argument. So they weren't denying it.
And evaluating plaintiff's claims that this, you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to send this to Jimmy door and I want him to, I cause he, you know,
I'm too stupid to be able to debunk this or say that it's actually fucking true.
I want to know. I want to know what love is.
I mean, this wouldn't surprise me. You know what I mean?
I would actually love it.
This got some fucking attention just to truly shut up all these fucking dopes in
Hollywood. You know, you know, back in the day. Yeah. I mean, I guess I,
I mean I think that, I mean it was, can do,
I'm not trying to be the spokesperson for fucking Western oil or whatever the
fuck people are trying to do out there, but like I,
I tried to like evenly trash everybody and I'm totally into conspiracy theory.
Like none of this is shocking to me.
You know,
I t I just think we're just inherently flood and I based that on myself
as I fucking, you know, I as like just fuck up all the time,
which is what just inherently flood people. All right Jimmy door.
Then we go, this is how dumb I am.
I'm going to send this to him and I'm just going to text, is this true?
You know, and he loves me enough to actually reply this.
I know part of him is going to feel sad that I'm as dumb as I am and then I have
his phone number. Um, yeah. I mean,
none of that surprises me. I mean it was,
he kind of felt that Bernie was getting boxed out and I guess maybe the
Democratic National Committee does have the,
I guess does have the right to do it the same way the NFL had the right to
suspend Tom Brady, whether he did anything or not. I mean,
when they took it to court, they go, yeah, this is bullshit.
You don't have enough fucking evidence. And they're like, well,
we're a corporation. Right. Does it cooperation? I have a right,
this is blended. Some play. Yes you do. Well, Tom Brady's our employee,
therefore he suspended. Um,
that's Kinda like what they did to Bernie Sanders and yes, I did.
Just compare him to Tom Brady. I think they have a lot in common.
I'm living in a retirement community at 33 years of age. What's up?
Freckled ball bag. Um,
a friend recently turned me onto your podcast. It's hilarious. Well thank you.
Thank you for preventing me from killing myself on my one hour commute to work.
Well, that's great. I like to, I like to do what I can,
although I am into population. Maybe I should take a control population control.
Maybe we should take a couple of weeks off. Uh, my wife,
28 and I 33 finally had enough money to buy her first home to what?
You guys are crushing it.
So he purchased a nice little townhouse in Connecticut.
We didn't know at the time,
but we were moving into a community that is potentially the evil offspring of a
retirement village and the house of wax. Uh, yeah.
Well that's what happens when you buy your first house. You so excited.
You don't drive around. You don't know the questions to ask now, you know.
Okay.
Are the people old, these shit around here. Just out of curiosity,
is this a drug filled neighborhood?
Is there any chemical fucking shit in the water?
What are the schools like? You know, all those questions you have to ask.
All right, we are nice, courteous people. And so we think
so. We think he's a, so don't take the anger in this email out of context.
Um, well he had a little perspective that we use.
If you said we're nice courtesy people, courteous people.
But the fact that you actually have the intelligence to say are so we think
understanding that there is another perspective in life other than your own.
We've helped some of our old ass neighbors carry shit, you know,
because they can't, with the osteoporosis and everything,
we wave and chat with them when walking our dog.
And we even hold the charity beer pong tournament in New York City every year to
raise money for ms, uh, unrelated to our community. But it shows we care.
Question Mark, I guess question Mark Anyhoo enough about us.
Uh,
this past weekend we had my brother and sister in law in town and invited
another couple over on Saturday, Saturday.
I'm sorry if I blew your eardrums out. I tried to pull it away enough. Uh,
I don't, I took it away at a time. Sorry. Uh,
we went to hang out at school at our, at our pool, sorry.
We took a float snacks, a couple of beers and a speaker.
They were five to seven other people at the pool, all in their hundreds.
It did not look like the pool scene from Caddyshack. Uh,
we hung out,
chatted sip to beer and listened on low to Jack Johnson or some other Melo soft
shit.
Monday morning at 10:00 AM the entire community got this email residents,
it was reported to the board and the management that over this past weekend
there was some owners and guests who behaved inappropriately,
loud and shout in conversations,
foul language and may have partaken in alcoholic beverages prior to or while
visiting the pool.
None of these things are acceptable and are also violation of the pool rules of
the Old Fox court.
Obviously you added that if [inaudible] said individuals were seeing behaving in
such a manner going forward, the police may be called and set.
Individuals will not be permitted to use the facilities and may also be subject
to a hearing in front of the board whereby fines may be imposed.
The pool facility is for the peaceful enjoyment of all residents and we hope to
keep it that way. Thank you.
Signed the old ass board of directors. Jesus Christ. Dude,
what the f you didn't realize you fucking bought a house in a retirement
community says first off,
let me say I've had,
I had nothing against the elderly. I love my grandparents. It's,
you don't have to stop establishing credibility.
You bought a fucking house as a buddy in the, in the,
it's like the movie cocoon, but if you jump in the pool,
you're still fucking old again. It, um, anyways,
I called her once a week.
I enjoy quiet and that in the couch for some scotch or an old fashioned and
shit. I still use hotmail. Yes,
we're a part of Hoa and in rules above, above about alcohol strengths.
The, at the pool you can only have two guests per household. Oh Shit.
We violated the covenant.
But this email from the board is still absurd right now. It's not absurd.
You just didn't do your homework. You didn't do your homework.
That's what happened.
You didn't do your homework and they just fucking rip the spread here with that
pen in the back pocket, waiting on my mother's fucking quilt here. Um,
on the fuck am I here? I got to go back to this here. By the way,
everybody thinks every sound of my podcast is a fart now because I hold this
thing to my chest and he fucking sound that's made dough.
You fucking ripped ass last week. Uh, I mean, maybe I did.
I don't think I, I don't feel that I am. Maybe I am. I don't know. Um,
but it's, I mean, I'm in my house, you know, I have to Fart. I let it go.
You can't fucking smell it. Deal with it. Um,
no dude is all on you. This is just, he said,
but loud conversations. What?
Drinking alcoholic beverages prior to visiting the pool area. You kidding me?
The police may be called get an f in life. Do Do.
This is their life. This is the end of their life. And they want quiet.
Okay? Half of them probably fought and fucking wars.
The last thing I need is you with your new fangled fucking Elvis' music.
That is Jack Johnson to them. Look at this is the deal.
You guys fucked up.
Okay?
You guys fucked up. All right. And this is part of buying your first house.
Okay. I bought my first house back in 2011.
Um,
and you know what I was like, wow, this is a great old house.
It has a lot of character and you know,
you know what my fucking old people at the pool was galvanized pipes in the
walls, cloth wiring, a gas leak flashing.
When I turned on the lights to possibly ignite the gas underneath my fucking
house, a wood rot, termites,
non permitted fucking building shit. I've just, you fucking name it,
put a new roof on it. That guy fucked up. He didn't reattach the thing.
The water came through. They blamed me. I just said fuck it.
I paid for it myself. This is part of it, dude.
I'm really sorry that you're going through this.
I'm sure there's somebody else old that will buy your fucking house.
Um,
other than that, I would just, you are in a communal area.
I would be quiet when you go down to the pool. I mean,
I try to look at the bright side.
At least nobody's going to be listening to loud fucking Benny Goodman music all
the way into the night because old people, you know,
they fall asleep like nine times a day. So,
and even if you don't like your neighbor, they're going to die soon.
There's a lot of positive ways to look at this and you can also,
you can always sell. So I would make the best of it. You can always Uber.
I would Uber,
I would go out and go get fucking hammered and be loud in the young part of town
and then come back.
Just make sure you get some sort of electric car to cruising up real quietly to
your fucking front door. I'm sorry you're going through that.
But what you learned is you have to fucking check out your neighborhood before
you, uh, you know, you gotta read everything,
you know, so that's the deal. All right. I hope it works out for you.
All right. Oh, guess who just texted me back?
This is why Jimmy door is to shit cause I just read shit and Jimmy gets to the
bottom. But this is what Jimmy just sent me back. Basically. Yes,
the judge left,
opened the door for the lawyers too to refile in a way that would be more
successful.
The important thing in this case is that the lawsuit forced the DNC lawyer to
admit in court that they don't have to run a fair primary and that they can pick
and choose whoever, whoever they want and can ignore the voters.
Uh, they can ignore the voters, will if they choose to do so.
The wikileaks emails revealed that the DNC was colluding with the Clinton
campaign and gave her an unfair advantage,
which is why Wasserman Schultz resigned before the DNC convention last summer.
The judge dismissed the case.
It appears to me based on the fact that plaintiff did not have stand standing to
sue and the federal court did not have jurisdiction in this case.
I am interviewing the lawyer who filed this case today,
so hopefully lots will be cleared up in that interview. So there you go.
Search Jimmy door. Um, I'll send out a link to [inaudible].
That's a comedian. That's, that's an informed guy here.
That thing was written here on eloquent. That was,
I actually sounded smart while reading that. Um, check that out.
Oh Man. Oh my God. Oh my God.
All those women who cried over fucking Hillary Clinton and she's just as fucking
filthy as this guy. Can you believe this? Trump. Can you fucking believe this?
Trump. That's all you hear out in fucking Hollywood land where I live.
And it's just like I want to, I hope it's true. So I'm gonna be like,
well what do you think about that?
And watch them completely dismiss it the same way to go back to Tom Brady or
I'll be all right. So He lets a concert, what? They air out of a ball.
What about when you guys did this and that the other people root for the wall?
That was no fucking big deal. Cause our team did it.
I fucking love it. I love it. Oh Jesus Christ. I love it. Okay.
Boss, racist, racist, racist. Question Mark.
Hey Billy. Booze bag. Ah, Billy. No Fun. 11 days. Motherfucker.
Uh, shut up. I know you're not drinking. Oh, he got me. Look at that. Um,
any more, it's all I could come up with. All right. Bill recently,
our company at an event where we give a tour to possible clients who will
partner with us in the future during this event,
our boss who is outgoing and funny,
was ironing white sheets and thought it'd be funny to poke fun at the KKK by
placing a white sheet over his head and saying, black lives matter.
Uh,
he immediately recognized the situation and took it off his head and address the
whole company.
The next day he apologized and made our counselors available to the company for
whoever was affected and offended. Jesus fucking Christ.
You've got to go through all of that.
I just love these people that are just so fucking,
I don't know where the fuck they live that they feel like I can do this in the
not going to have a problem. But then everybody's like so fucking hurt.
They need to be like counseled.
Why don't you just try to get out of your job for a couple of hours?
Just walk up to the guy and say you're a fucking asshole.
And then if you want the guy fired, just say that.
So I'm just gonna sit there and hold your hand. I'm,
the only problem was that he left out the black lives mattered part in the first
meeting and simply said, oh, wait a minute. So when I would, he's saying, okay,
wait a second.
The only problem was that he left out the black life lives matter part in the
first meeting and simply said, he placed the sheet over his head,
which is where the outrage came from. You know, dude,
that's one of the most important part information,
most important information in this fucking story.
And you left out some words here.
The only problem was that he left out the black lives mattered part in the first
meeting and simply said, he plays
the sheet over his head,
which is where we're WGRE we're, the outrage came from to,
what am I supposed to do with this? And the counselor meeting with everyone.
I couldn't help but notice only white middle aged women were trashing the guy.
They were crying, et cetera.
Okay?
Not One minority in that room said they were affected.
It pissed me off because it was almost insulting to minorities watching this.
What if there was actually a minority who was actually racially discriminate
against and went to court and wasn't listened to to it?
I don't know what you're talking about right now.
I'm 90% sure these women were just looking for money.
It's not like our boss tried to hide or make excuses,
so the white women got offended. What am I,
this is like a fucking beat sheet for a script that isn't written yet.
What white middle aged women were trashing the guy, they were crying,
et cetera.
That fucking sentence ended.
Then he began a new paragraph with that and then starts talking about the
minority women there. I don't, I don't know what you're talking about here, sir.
Okay.
Okay. So, okay, so you're asking me what, okay,
what am I opinions you think these women are just looking for an opportunity to
sue sue, s e w
so for money or do you think they actually believe these ladies were offended?
Thanks, Bill. I don't know what you're talking about here, sir. I have no idea.
I have no idea.
I'm I making fun of white women for acting like they were offended and crying
because you think I have no idea. I don't know what Sir proofread. Okay.
I'm not a good speller either but you know,
I do know where the spell check is and I hit the button and it erases all my
impurities. Alright. My fiance is in into fucking other men.
Okay. He says I feel or she said, I don't want,
what the fuck this is what gender this is. He said,
I feel like this is a slightly different yet amusing take on relationship issues
and would love to hear your tackle. You tackle this in a podcast basically.
I really like watching my girl. Fuck other men.
It's not a cuckold thing because I'll fucker right after and it's always the
best sex we ever had. Right after.
You don't ever shower first sir. Right after. Okay. Thank you. No,
I don't judge. Whatever you want to do, if that's what you guys are in.
My issue is that our sex is already great and I'm well above average in size and
stamina. So it's hard for her to find another guy.
She's actually interested in, oh Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ. You started all the way to the left.
Now we're all the way to the right. Oh Wow. Yeah. This guy,
this fucking guy here. You know, I don't mind.
I don't mind her fucking other guys. I can handle it.
Cause at the end of the day, my Dick show big, nobody can follow me.
I'm okay now I'm judging the guy. I don't know why I'm doing I.
This is just all over the fucking map.
I don't push the issue because I'm confident in my abilities.
Evidently so confident you gotta fucking write an email about it and don't want
her to have a bad time simply for my pleasure.
But I wanted to know your opinion on the subject.
We have threesomes with other women.
God bless you and I can't even get ended them.
Okay.
So I can't judge her. I love her.
And our amazing sex has been a driving factor after almost four years. Yet.
There's something about fucking her after she's been with another man that is so
hot to me,
I can't actually accurately explain it and she just doesn't seem into it because
as she puts it, I do it better. Dude,
this is one of the greatest emails. I hope you if VM, if you just made this up,
I would really appreciate your opinion on this weird kind of relationship where
the issue for me is that I can't get off because the girl as incredible as she
is is too perfect. What?
Well, the issue for me is that I can't get off because the girl
as incredible is, she is is too perfect. So to weigh her,
to make her not perfect is to have you watch your fuck. Another guy,
she got a giant Dick and you enjoy it and you kinda like want to show like
that is the only way I can look at it.
This is what you like the head like the best comedian in the fucking country.
All right,
but there's still some level of insecurity you have that you have to go on on
these, these,
these shows where the comics aren't at your level and you have to go on last and
you have to fucking kill harder and kill longer than anybody else to prove that
you are the best comedian in the fucking country, if not the world,
if not the fucking universe. Right. Is that what it is?
Is it the fact that you know, that you fucking nail in or better than these,
these other fucking guys,
they come out with their average Dick's and their little fucking dicks and she's
bored shitless. Do you make the other people watch?
You know what I mean? Like you helping out their golf swing it all, yeah.
You keep lifting your head.
You gotta fucking keep your head down as you follow through. Dude. I don't,
I don't have the problems you have sir. All right. I am very followible.
Um, I have no idea. Uh,
I, I do what I, I have no idea.
That is like I would send that into a,
can you please go on Dr Phil?
Cause I just want to watch him and see what goes on in his eyes when he listens
to this story where he just goes like, so you NIAID,
I have another man have sex with your woman where the penile devise that is
smaller than yours in order for you to get off. Last words you're saying.
And you know, Doctor Phil's got some giant x comp Dick, right? You know,
he's got some fucking huge Hogan. That's what you do.
That's the end of the episode is you go in the back and you watch doctor Phil.
Fuck you
with the sweat pouring off his fucking head and you're just sitting there
relaxed and confident. Right. That'd be funny. He probably,
he probably wouldn't get naked. He just dropped his pants down.
He'd still have his fucking wingtips on. Um,
you know what he'd do to try to [inaudible] our ear in the fucking, you know,
this dirty talk will be how much fucking money he's worth. Uh,
he want to go to Oprah's tonight. Hi. You want to go?
Do you want to go to Oprah's tonight? I can make it happen,
but that's, I'm sorry. I know this is a fucked up podcast, but I didn't,
I didn't, I wasn't the one that took it into that area. All right.
Other people did. Ah, that was really weird. That was a really weird visual.
The whole thing was weird. And who knew? Who the fuck knew?
Who the fuck knew that this podcast would start as innocently as it did?
Talking about Hitler getting his make a wish and what end.
So fucked up with a, whenever the fuck it is.
I was just describing. All right. That's the podcast.
Everybody [inaudible] um, please, uh,
download the new queens of the stone age album. Please buy some tickets to my,
a show at the surf ball room in a,
was it clear Lake Iowa? It's going to be a fucking amazing night. And, uh,
what else? What else? What else, what else? I'll post those videos for you.
That's it. And congratulations.
Everybody that rented the fight and a and enjoyed it.
I don't wanna ruin your fucking time. And, uh, I think that's it.
I'll check it audio on Thursday. Go. Fuck yes.
Oh Duh.